these are the Perils of a journey we saw
last year more than any other
Panic fear and Horror in freezing
December Waters
that day four people died
after migrant boat got into difficulties
call to safety by a fishing crew though
small boat arrivals relatively rare
before 2019 heading into the new year
campaigners say providing more safe
routes to Asylum is the solution
ukrainians were given safe passage to
get here if we extended safe passage to
other refugees I'm not talking about
open borders I'm talking about people
who are assassed to have a viable Asylum
plane if we gave them safe passage so
they did not have to get on boats that
would stop small the Small Boat
Crossings it would put people's
Smugglers out of business that's
everything our government says that they
want the government's approach a string
of announcements from the Rwanda
deportation scheme still in the courts
to a new small boats command to try and
disrupt more Crossings crossing the
channel
in unseaworthy vessels is a lethally
dangerous endeavor
so for this reason above all that we are
working so hard to destroy the business
model of the
evil organized criminals who treat human
beings as cargo
Channel Crossings are part of a
political debate that has a harsh
reality more people than ever are making
the treacherous trip across the world's
busiest shipping Lane including 90 more
on Christmas Day
experts can remember the clamp down on
Lorry Crossings the attempt to curb boat
Journeys much more complex the
government don't have total control over
what's going on in France with with the
lorries we controlled it completely and
we're reliant on the French
um to control the people coming off the
beaches so the government's answer is to
try and make the UK as unattractive as
it can
and that's what the Rwanda scheme really
is all about
over 12 months there's been even more
debate about how they're dealt with
but very little doubt about one thing
just how dangerous these Journeys are
shinki marike Sky News Dover